[Applause]
the junior doctors are still out
their senior colleagues pulled in to try
and fill the gaps
one of them agreed to take us into his
day at the emergency department in
lewisham in South London the last time
we covered Virginia doctor strikes it
was incredibly busy so we'll see what
today brings this week is about
prioritizing emergency care okay so
halfway through the shift and the
pressure is now starting to ramp up
number of intendencies has increased
significantly since this morning and
Majors cubicles are now well occupied
the warnings were soon going out to
patients about delays in this trust I'm
working inside the system system is a
bit broken
um and we need to fix it and if we don't
pay our staff
you know what they deserve for the
conditions they're working under and the
responsibilities and expectations that
they have you know then then they'll
just get up on me
and then the NHS will be in any more
prices than it is coming the Westminster
governments say they want a fair deal
but the junior doctors pay demand of 35
is unrealistic thank you patients are
caught in the middle but at least Phil
can get on with his life he volunteers
at a food bank in South London it was
his cancer checkup that was postponed by
the strike
he's dismayed that the government has
yet to negotiate I know they're going to
have to do it
I would have delayed months they will
delay further months and where the
people suffer people who are in Far More
Jeopardy than I am
in loads more pain than I am loads more
anxiety than I am
everything points to this just carrying
on if the government won't come to the
table
I would expect there to be further
action so the stress on the system and
the people within it just builds now
like most of my colleagues I stayed a
little bit longer just to finish a few
things for my patients
it's been very busy this afternoon and
quite stressful the Department's full
but everybody's worked tirelessly to
look after our patients England is
halfway through this walkout and the
pain is starting to show for patients
and the service they pay for and rely so
much on
Tom Parmenter Sky News